shooting after a high school graduation
ceremony in Virginia this was in
Richmond yesterday during what should
have been a moment of celebration for
families there instead two people killed
including an 18 year old who had
graduated just minutes earlier five
people wounded overall and a witness
said that some of these victims were
still in their cap and gowns police have
arrested a 19-year-old suspect who they
say will be charged with two counts of
second-degree murder the shooting
happened as dozens filed out of a nearby
graduation ceremony at the Altria
theater behind me and into this park
where the shooter opened fire shooting
after a high school graduation ceremony
in Virginia this was in Richmond
yesterday during what should have been a
moment of celebration for families there
instead two people killed including an
18 year old who had graduated just
minutes earlier five people wounded
overall and a witness said that some of
these victims were still in their cap
and gowns police have arrested an
year old